this week's episode is brought to you in
part by Kiwi Co Q eco creates supercool
hands-on projects for kids of all ages
they make learning about science
technology engineering art and math fun
inspire creative confidence this year
with Kiwi Co Q eco is offering science
magazine podcast listeners the chance to
try them for free to redeem this offer
and learn more visit kiwi cocom slash
magazine welcome to the science podcast
for January 25th 2019 I'm Sarah Crespi
in this week's show I talked with
reporter Jason Fox about air pollution
from marijuana farms and how federal
restrictions make it difficult to study
the environmental impact of growing
cannabis Megan Cantwell Indiana small
discuss how modern foods processed and
packed with sugars and fats may be
disrupting the communication between the
gut and the brain and books editor
Valerie Thompson interviews author Erica
moolam about her book creatures of pain
the hunt for human nature in Cold War
America which traces the rise and fall
of the idea that our capacity for
violence and killing is what makes us
human is marijuana growing contributing
to air pollution one of the problems
with studying marijuana is that it's not
legal at the federal level in the United
States so there are states where it's
legal to consume it and where it's legal
to grow it and sell it but they are not
allowed to use federal funds to study it
I have freelance reporter Jason outs
here he looked at this issue in Denver
Colorado where marijuana is legal and
large operations where people are
growing cannabis in warehouses have
sprung up along the highway researchers
wanted to know if some of the chemicals
that are emitted by these plants are
damaging to the environment and they had
to kind of go into their garage and try
it there can you talk about what the
experimental setup was like the garage
setup hoods it was pretty pretty
bare-bones it's just a shelving unit
there are
lawnmowers and bikes all around it's
certainly not the
that I think you would want if you're
growing plants for any sort of
scientific study and how did the plants
turn out that that grew in these garage
conditions they were described to me as
is pretty pathetic that's something that
was sellable not something that was
really up to par with what the industry
is growing you know from what I
understand some of the plants that are
commercially grown they can be up to six
feet tall the leaves are just giant but
the problem is that they can't use the
normal facilities the researchers can't
use in normal facilities that they would
if they were growing something a little
bit less controversial like hops or
tobacco exactly exactly even in a state
like Colorado where recreational
marijuana is legal you can't bring it
into a federally funded facility there's
concern that they could lose their
funding and they were trying to figure
out whether these volatile organic
compounds called terpenes were
accumulating in high enough levels that
they don't just affect the indoor air
quality but also the outdoor air quality
what would happen if a lot of terpenes a
lot of volatile organic compounds were
escaping from these operations where
they're growing cannabis on the large
scale in Denver Denver is kind of an
interesting case Denver is dealing with
an ozone problem it's been in federal
non-attainment which means it's
violating federal health standards for a
number of years now ozone is formed when
volatile organic compounds like these
terpenes mix with nitrogen dioxide
that's pollution that can come from
tailpipes of cars from industrial
sources Denver is what's considered voz
limited which means that it has a lot of
sources of nitrogen dioxide not so many
sources of volatile organic compounds
which means that the more VOCs you're
adding to the environment the more
opportunity there is to make ozone so
when you're talking about putting 600 or
so growing facilities in Denver you're
adding a lot of these VOCs which can
then help form ozone the marijuana
plants are they particularly rich in
this when they grow are they releasing a
lot more than any other kind of plant
the industry is actually trying to
maximize production of terpenes the
smell
comes off of cannabis which you know a
lot of people call the the dank smell
that's terpenes and there have been a
lot of complaints about odor coming off
of marijuana growing facilities
especially some of the outdoor
facilities in states like California
well that's the same thing what they're
complaining about our terpene emissions
now it doesn't matter so much in rural
environments where there's not a lot of
nitrogen oxide production but in a city
like Denver that could be a big problem
depending on what the volume is right
what about the people that are in these
warehouses are they endanger from being
exposed to these terpenes that's one of
the next big topics that they want to
look at is you know what does it mean to
be breathing in these emissions all day
what does it mean to be working with
them and the implications really aren't
known again just because research has
been so hard to do on this industry you
know it's funny I talked to a researcher
from the desert Research Institute who
did some field studies looking at this
as well and he and his team complained
that they would come back to the lab and
everything would just reek of cannabis
you know they said their clothes even
the papers that they were using to write
down their notes would just smell days
later his thinking is this has gotta
mean something and he wants to do some
study on that well what was the outcome
of this pilot study carried out in a
garage looking at what's coming off of
these pathetic plants that you don't so
what they were looking to do was do what
are called enclosure studies so they
were taking the plans that they were
growing putting them under essentially
just a bag and sucking out the emissions
there and this was the first study to do
enclosure Studies on Canada's plants and
they were really trying to quantify what
are the different terpenes sort of the
volume of these different species of
terpenes yeah and were they able to get
any kind of data that would be helpful
for modeling this oh definitely but I
think everybody acknowledges the best
way to do this study is to go into
commercial facilities really look at an
environment that's designed to create
terpenes and is that is that the next
step that's the next step so the
Colorado Department of Public Health and
Environment is doing a field study which
should be kicking off next month in
February where there
going to go into four different growing
facilities two very large ones two more
boutique ones and they're going to be
setting up canisters throughout these
facilities at different points in the
growing process to measure the vo C
emissions that come off the plans
they're also going to have a lot more
access to the inventory that's in these
facilities the facilities are gonna be
sharing what strange they're growing how
many plants would be strained they're
growing so this is going to give a much
better accounting of in a commercial
facility that's designed to grow plants
to their maximum terpene production what
are the VOCs coming off is there some
kind of policy implication to this
ongoing study at the moment there's not
a policy implication agriculture is
exempt from federal air quality
regulations the EPA doesn't recognize
cannabis as an industry so they're going
to be no federal rules coming down
limiting emissions what the state is
really hoping to do is number one
quantify the emissions get a better
understanding of it
number two turn around to the industry
and say look this is your potential
impact on air quality here are some
voluntary steps that you can take now
the good news is there's actually a
pretty easy set of steps that the
industry could take there are carbon
filtration systems that they can put on
exhaust systems and these are gonna
filter out somewhere close to 98 or 99%
of the VOCs before they reach the air
and some facilities are already using
them for odor control the hope is that
by helping to quantify this and show the
industry its potential impact they can
encourage more of these filters and
really show the industry what's the best
way to use them very interesting okay
what did I miss
I feel like we covered a lot of the the
ground that was in your in your stories
or anything you feel like we left out
there are a lot of federal restrictions
here in the US because of the federal
government stance on marijuana where a
lot of people are now looking is north
of the border
Canada legalized recreational marijuana
nationally and the hope is that can be
an opportunity where you have a
government that is more supportive of
marijuana and certainly of cannabis
research so the hope is that there can
be some partnerships with Canadian
universities or the Canadian government
to help do some of this research alright
thank you so much Jason yeah happy to do
it okay Jason flouts is a freelance
writer
based in Denver you can find a link to
his story at science magpie casts stay
tuned for Megan Cantwell's interview
with Dana small on how the gut brain
connection may be disrupted by modern
foods
[Music]
this week's episode is brought to you in
part by Kiwi Co Q eco creates supercool
hands-on projects for kids that make
learning about steam fun with a Q eco
subscription each month the kid in your
life being your neighbor your nephew
your niece your own kid will receive a
fun engaging new project that will
develop their creativity and confidence
the projects are designed to spark that
creativity get them tinkering and
learning and this is for kids of all
ages
Kiwi Co has seven types of crates to
choose from we've got the tadpole crates
for infants koala crate to engage
naturally curious preschoolers like mine
all the way up to the Eureka crate for
anyone over 14 which includes me I guess
anybody over 14 every crate includes the
supplies needed for that month's project
detailed easy-to-follow instructions and
an educational magazine to learn more
about that crates themed everything is
created by a cue eCos team of in-house
product designers and rigorously tested
by kits which means yes it's fun yes
they learn something and yes they cannot
break it very easily q eCos mission is
to empower kids not just to make a
project but to make a difference
q eco is offering science magazine
podcast listeners a chance to try them
for free to redeem this offer and learn
more visit QE co.com slash magazine
[Music]
the moment you see something or think
about something
you're going to have changes in your gut
that are going to signal to your brain
so there's there's a lot of
bi-directional communication going on
within the past few decades the diet of
people around the world has changed with
the introduction of processed foods I'm
Megan Cantwell and I'm here with Dana
small to talk about how these processed
foods may be complicating the
communication between the brain and the
gut hey Dana hey when was this link
between the gut and the brain discovered
I can think back to a paper by adults in
1947 and he made this famous conclusion
that rats eat for calories but what it
meant was that there had to be some sort
of signal in the gut that was
transferring the information about the
calories to the brain what part of the
brain is the gut communicating to and
what does the brain interpret this
signal as so there's a lot of different
areas that are being communicated to the
pathway that is best known that was
recently described by hen at all in cell
paper goes through the vagus nerve and
then into the hind brain so from the
hind brain it then goes to the midbrain
where all the dopamine cells are and
those cells then project to the striatum
when you have activation in the gut like
right away you get regulation of a
central dopamine circuit you wrote about
how processed foods are complicating how
the brains interpreting this signaling
could you talk specifically about how
sugar from processed foods is making it
more complicated really our food
environment has changed dramatically in
the last 50 years and so it's sort of
out of step with many of these old
circuits so modern foods there's lots of
carbohydrate and lots of sugar in them
but there's also artificial sweeteners
through a series of studies we found
that the beverages that we were using
they had different metabolic effects
depending on the ratio of sweetness to
calories so those beverages that were
sort of mismatched where they were too
sweet or not sweet enough for the amount
of calories that were there their
metabolic response was blunted so that
means they were less rewarding
and in fact people didn't learn to like
those flavors associated with that
particular combination so this is an
unanticipated effect that in fact it
kind of backfires because it changes it
shifts the metabolic response when the
metabolic response goes down it means
the glucose is not being used so that
means that it's not enough for the
glucose to be in the gut or in the blood
it actually has to be used by the cells
as a fuel in order to be rewarding how
do you process foods with fat and
carbohydrates complicate this signaling
you have a lot of the processed foods
that are out there the ones at least
that we crave like donuts and pizza
those have carbohydrate in the form of
starches which are broken down into
glucose once they get to the gut and
they also really high in fat if you look
at the food environment pre let's say
1800s there's very very few foods that
have both fat and carbohydrate in them
at least to any great extent and so the
brains never really seen these signals
together at the same time one of the
discoveries in the last few years is
that there are these separate pathways
for fat and for carbohydrate one of the
questions that we had asked is whether
or not they could interact and indeed
they do so both of those pathways are
going to dopamine circuits so what does
the brains respond to these processed
foods if you look at brain imaging
studies with people viewing these
pictures of either foods that are high
in fat high in carbohydrate or high in
fat and carbohydrate their responses in
these central dopamine circuits are
stronger for the foods that have the fat
and the carbohydrate but the interesting
thing is those foods have the same
amount of calories as the other foods
that are just bad or just carbohydrates
they're all equally caloric they're also
all equally liked and they're equally
familiar nevertheless their brain reward
circuits the striatum in particular will
respond stronger to those foods with the
fat in the carbohydrate so this is then
evidence that these two signals can
interact to potentiate
so the striatum is preferring things
with fats and carbohydrates together I
don't know if it's preferring them that
the response is certainly stronger to
those okay yep
and those those responses are thought to
be learning signals and so strong
response can translate not necessarily
integrator liking but it can translate
into greater learning hmm so the
learning is happening unconsciously
exactly a lot of this learning is
occurring in circuits that existed way
before there was cortex in consciousness
and so this very simple learning circuit
it works perfectly well without any
conscious thought without any perception
of liking so for example you can
conditioned brain responses to different
foods and the more metabolic response
you have the greater the brain response
to that food or that flavor what is
interesting is that those areas which
include the striatum but also the
hypothalamus so the sort of the master
regulator of feeding those responses
while they are very very closely related
to those metabolic signals they are
unrelated to how much people say they
like the thing
are there other studies that demonstrate
how this signaling works there's now two
studies including one by my lab but also
another one but Anand a group at McGill
University where they use the Becker de
Groote auction tasks so people are shown
pictures of foods they're given a
certain amount of money they're hungry
and they have to bid against the
computer in order to earn the
possibility of eating one of those foods
immediately after they're in a scanner
what he found and what our group found
is that the amount that people are
willing to bid depends on the actual
energy density of the food but not on
the estimated energy density of the food
so we're now we're talking about
nutritive signals one is veridical one
is actually the nutritive signal related
to the energy density thing and then the
other one is how much you think and what
determines reinforcing or how much
you're willing to pay is the actual
energy density not the estimated energy
density and in fact people are really
bad
to estimating the energy density and
it's also not related to liking it so
this does mean then that these signals
are influencing behavior at least how
much you're willing to pay even though
they're not being translated into
conscious knowledge of how much calories
are there and even though you don't like
it any more than some other food you're
still gonna be biased towards it if it
has more energy-dense so that means that
it's not enough for the glucose to be in
the gut or in the blood it actually has
to be used by the cells as a fuel in
order to be rewarding so if the
nutritional content of processed food
isn't being communicated properly is
there any way to correct or unlearn
these reinforcements that's an area that
needs a lot of further research my
suspicion is that learning happens and
learning keeps happening you could learn
to dislike something I mean the classic
example is conditioned taste aversion
learning you can take something you
really like and then one time you get
sick on it and then you will never touch
it again flavor learning is very
flexible you know you always hear about
the modern food environment which you
know is filled with hyper palatable
energy dense inexpensive foods blame is
put on pleasure but actually a lot of
these foods are not hyper palatable so
it's not that they're incredibly
delicious the first time you have them
what they are is incredibly reinforcing
and their nutritive bang is higher I
would say than their then how
pleasurable they are so the pleasure it
could be a force for good because it
shunts the decision away from these
unconscious circuits towards more
conscious perceptions and sort of more
goal directed behaviors which is more
under your control alright thank you so
much sir Dana small is a professor of
psychiatry at the yale school of
medicine and director of the modern diet
and physiology Research Center you can
find a link to her insight at science
magog slash podcasts up next we have
books at
Valerie Thompson and author Erica malum
discussing the rise and fall of the
killer ape hypothesis of humanity are
people people because of our capacity
for violence
[Music]
welcome to the first book segment of
2019 in December we said goodbye to our
longtime producer general back so while
we search for her replacement you're
stuck with me Valerie Thompson the book
review editor here at science as your
host today our guest is historian Erica
Millan and we'll be discussing her new
book creatures of Kane the hunt for
human nature in Cold War America Erica
we're so happy to have you here I am so
delighted to be here thank you very much
absolutely so let's dive right in can
you begin with like a brief summary of
what the book is about it's a book that
is fundamentally about what it means to
be human from the 1950s through to the
1980s and it's about to interwove
installs one is the rise and fall of
what I call the killer ape theory and
the other is about how scientific
publication works for general readers
let's get a little bit more into this
killer ape hypothesis sure there were
three men who were primarily associated
with the killer ape theory for popular
readers one of them was Robert Audrey
who actually trained as a theatre writer
and he ends up becoming interested in
human nature in the 1950s as a result of
being hosted on assignment by reporter
magazine to Africa and it's in Africa
that he becomes fascinated by the idea
that what makes humans human is the
moment when human ancestors picked up a
bone or a piece of rock and realized
that it could be used as a weapon to
kill and that it is in fact this moment
of of aggression of potentially
murderous intent that provided the the
motive energy that made humans what they
were then in the 1950s and 1960s as he
was writing and this idea that what is
special about human beings originated in
violence was what people called the
killer ape theory of humanity it was
also associated with Konrad Lorenz who
was trained in the study of
behavior and with Desmond Morris trained
under Nikolaas Tinbergen Oxford for his
PhD and then he gets a job at the London
Zoo
so Ardrey is different because he's
actually not trained as a scientist
unlike Morris and Lorentz but it's in
fact his books that become so popular
that this idea begins to gain currency
among general readers what was it that
was so compelling to general audiences
he's a very dramatic writer for our jury
he believed that in fact his training in
the humanities provided him with insight
into what it meant to be human so that
in fact he was perhaps even better
suited than a scientist who had not been
infused with humanist vigor to be able
to understand the secrets of what it
meant to be human and certainly that
comes through in his writing and so
these books were invigorating
they were controversial certainly not
everyone who read them thought oh our
tree he's so great many people thought
that they found his vision of what it
meant to be human frustrating and
dehumanizing that by by investing in
what it meant to be human in violence
then what happens to all of those
qualities about human beings that we
actually value - our love our compassion
our capacity to cooperate and there was
a belief at the time that in fact other
animals did not kill other adults of
their same species that in fact that was
a uniquely human trait right and you get
into that a little bit in the book as
well as kind of like how the hypothesis
fell out of favor was with these new
primate studies that we were starting to
see primates come in because they are
ecologically quite similar to where
paleoanthropologists think humans might
have lived early in our history and so
in the open savanna these species that
first gets used as the primary primate
example are baboons and then slowly over
the 1960s thanks to the work of Jane
Goodall and then eventually
and Fosse and Barrett a called accosts
there's an increasing tendency to look
at the great apes to look at chimpanzees
and then gorillas and orangutans
respectively and chimpanzees provide a
really different kind of model than
baboons
so whereas baboons appear to be fierce
horror goal and with profound sexual
dimorphism between the males and the
females chimpanzees people thought in
the 1960s as a result of goodall's early
work that they were primarily peaceful
they were rather cooperative in
comparison to the baboons and then also
that they were mostly forest dwelling
and so it was this ecological difference
that got mapped onto an evolutionary
transition in human history that
potentially we had been like chimpanzees
earlier but then in the transition to
the savanna became more like the baboons
became more aggressive and territorial
so let's switch gears a little bit sure
let's talk about I know that you've done
a great deal of scholarship in this area
already I was wondering if there's
anything that was really surprising to
you when you were doing the research for
this book in particular what I found
really shocking was that when the new
Hollywood films started to make an
appearance in the late 1960s and early
1970s and there's a whole slew of them
by film directors like Sam Peckinpah and
Stanley Kubrick many of them were
derided as being phenomenally violent
and in defending their movies against
criticisms like these both Kubrick and
Peckinpah invoke artery and this vision
of human nature as evidence that all
they are doing is showing humanity as it
really ought to be depicted and that
previous Hollywood films had softened
what it truly meant to be human because
of the Hays Code of moral conduct and so
finally they were able to make real
movies about real men that's fascinating
I feel like the idea that they were
using this kind of scientific evidence
to
justified violence in the movies yes
what was the impetus behind this book
what compelled you to write it I got
interested in this project as a result
of beginning to explore the history of a
great school scientific curriculum
project called man a course of study and
man a course of study was directed by
Jerome Bruner who is a cognitive
psychologist out of Harvard University
and he assembled a team of experts in
order to be able to put together this
curriculum and they came together with
grade school teachers in order to build
a program around three central questions
what is human about human beings how did
they get that way and how can they be
made more so it is a progressive
anti-racist self-consciously optimistic
vision of what it means to be human and
the idea is to train 5th graders in
anthropological study and to get them to
think about what it means to be human
first through thinking about what's
different between humans and other
animals and then by studying another
culture and beginning to recognize the
ways in which our culture and their
culture are similar it's this great
curriculum project I was totally
fascinated by it
and I started looking into the history
and was horrified to discover that in
the 1970s it gets picked up by
congressional representative John Conlan
who is a Republican from the state of
Arizona and he is so upset by this
program that he calls it repugnant and
vulgar and he insists the grade school
children are impressionable and quote
should be shown the beauty and wonders
of life not just its see MIA stand most
uncivilized aspects and I thought wow
how is this program so many different
things to different people what has
changed between the 1960s and the 1970s
that makes it possible for Bruner and
the scientists who worked on it
be so optimistic and for Conlan to be so
horrified and I became interested in the
change in politics of human nature and
what was going on in American society
that rendered this same set of
information so politically different
this is kind of a relatively recent
period of history but I was wondering if
you had any thoughts on what messages or
lessons that contemporary scientists
particularly our readers I'm thinking of
will take away from the book I think
there's probably two of them one of them
is that the power of what I call
colloquial science scientific
publications that are designed not just
to reach people who are experts in that
area but also scientists in other areas
and general readers not necessarily
trained in the sciences that the power
of colloquial science to inspire the
next generation of students is
phenomenal and I did a whole variety of
oral history interviews with scientists
over the course of this project and one
of the things that I found amazing was
that they invoke these popular science
books these colloquial books as the
inspiration for getting interested in
the big questions about what it means to
be human or why to be a scientist in the
first place
and so I really think that we need to
think of colloquial science also as a
part of science today and the scientific
conversation today because it plays a
super important role the second is more
scientifically oriented I suppose which
is that stories about human nature are
phenomenally malleable politically and
the kinds of moral lessons that people
have drawn from humanity's deep history
have changed over time and although
biological theories of human nature can
and have been used to debase some
members of society as less valuable than
others they have also been used to
promote egalitarian conceptions of
humanity as a whole and I think it's
important to keep track of these
different kinds of messages and to think
about
what it is that scientists and
historians of science want to say in
their work for general readers thank you
so much for joining us today Eric I
really appreciate it thank you so much
Valerie I very much enjoyed the
conversation that was Valerie Thompson
and Erica moolam discussing the book
creatures of Cain the hunt for human
nature in Cold War America you can find
more author interviews and book reviews
on our books blog books at all valiant
Valerie we'll be back at the end of next
month with another book for your stack
and that concludes this edition of the
science podcast if you have any comments
or suggestions for the show write to us
at science podcast at AAAS 0rg and we
are looking for another book reviewer to
fill in some time so if you have science
and radio experience get in touch you
can subscribe to the show anywhere you
get your podcasts or you can listen on
the science website that science
Magdeburg slash podcasts to place an ad
on the science podcast contact mid-roll
comm the show was produced by Sarah
Crespi and Megan Cantwell and edited by
Paula G Jeffrey could compose the music
on behalf of science magazine and it's
publisher triple-s thanks for joining us